over the past four decades in an effort
to effectively restore diseased lost or
damaged tissue medical science has
explored a variety of creative solutions
techniques involving synthetics
biosynthetic constructs and allografts
tissue donated from one person to
another have advanced significantly in
recent years for allografts efforts have
been directed primarily at removing
those elements which contribute to
immunological rejection to minimize the
risk of rejection successful ala graphic
transplantation hinges critically on the
ability to render these tissues
acellular that is removing all cells
from the tissue while d cellular ization
eventually became possible researchers
found themselves faced with time
consuming processes immunological
complications and the risk of tissue
matrix degradation recently however
researchers at LifeNet health have
developed a highly efficient innovative
process that successfully addresses and
overcomes these obstacles the matrix LD
cellular ization process represents an
exciting new paradigm shift for
allograft preparation and validation the
proprietary matrix L process is unique
in its ability to quickly and reliably
produce a cellular allograft tissue
while retaining the native biomechanical
strength of the tissue the first step
involves the use of a specialized
detergent known to be an efficient
soluble Iser without affecting the
integrity of the protein in the tissue
to degrade nucleic acids a recombinant
endonuclease is used
unlike other d cellular is a ssin
methods that may use bovine derived
endonucleases
as additional insurance the maitre sell
process employs a unique filter system
that removes previously extracted cells
from the chamber and prevents them from
recirculating into the other chambers
step two involves a rinse that ensures
the D cellular is a ssin process is
complete the rinse uses USP sterile
water and a mixed bed of an Yin exchange
resin and hydrophobic at solvent resin
this serves to bind the processing
reagents from the previous rinse and any
hydrophobic cellular components step
three is intended to preserve the tissue
the tissue is bathed in a life net
health proprietary solution this is a
naturally occurring molecule within the
body and acts as a water replacement
agent when it is ready for use the
tissue is simply prepared and the
proprietary solution is rinsed away
while others require one to two weeks
the maitre SEL process requires only two
days reducing the opportunity for water
mediated lysis of the tissues collagen
and elastin scaffold matrix L provides
for a unique multifaceted approach to
tissue disinfection while others offer
only one unlike other competitive
processes matrix L does not use any
animal derived reagents our process
verifies 100% of the D cellular is a
ssin process for all grafts in addition
to the process being validated and
unlike other competitive processes we
assess and verify every lot of donor
tissue following D cellular ization
ensuring the highest level of detection
for potential remaining DNA
make Rachelle the future of allograft
bio implant D cellular ization